de rectification de vote sur la
proposition de loi pour une école de la
liberté de l'égalité des chances et de
la laïcité au scrutin de numéro 270 les
sénateurs capuche chassins de colle
paoligajin verzelaine wattlead et
Menonville souhaitent voter contre et
les sénateurs guerriot malurai et
Colette Melo souhaite voter pour merci
beaucoup monsieur le Président
de votre mise au point qui figuiera dans
l'analyse politique ensuite la parole
est à monsieur benaroche qui a souhaité
faire rappel au règlement et la parole
la violence que connaît notre pays et
que nous condamons et le septum d'une
démocratie malade il n'est plus possible
de voter des lois contre la majorité du
pays et de réprimer la contestation
sociale par la force il nous faut donc
appeler le pouvoir exécutif à
l'apaisement plutôt que de la vitesse à
poursuivre sa dérive autoritaire et il
libéral contrairement aux intentions des
auteurs de ce texte n'est pas rendre
service à nos forces de l'ordre qui ne
font que respecter les consignes de leur
autorité à l'opposé de cette démarche
contre-productive nous demandant au
gouvernement de faire des gestes
d'apaisement pour protéger à la fois les
forces de l'ordre et les manifestants
nous lui demandons également de revoir
de forte encore la doctrine de matières
de l'ordre pour revenir à un usage
proportionné de la force afin de
restaurer la confiance entre la police
et la population pour toutes ces raisons
nous ne participerons pas davantage à ce
débat et nous ne prendrons pas par au
vote
mon cher collègue pour la partie de
votre intervention
pour la partie de votre intervention qui
est relative au règlement
une réponse vous sera apportée par la
présidente
dans la discussion générale de la
proposition de résolution que nous
abordons maintenant pardon l'ordre du
jour appelle l'examen de la proposition
de résolution exprimant la gratitude et
la reconnaissance du Sénat au membre des
forces de l'ordre déployées sur tout le
territoire national
présenté en application l'article 34-1
de la Constitution par Monsieur Bruno
retaillod et les membres du groupe les
républicains Monsieur Hervé marseillais
plusieurs de leurs collègues la demande
d'inscription l'ordre du jour émane donc
des groupes les républicains et Union
Centriste et dans la discussion générale
à part le président Bruno Retailleau
auteur de la proposition de résolution
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
mais chers collègues cette résolution
que nous avons déposée avec mon collègue
de l'Union centriste Hervé Marseille
ça n'est pas seulement un acte
symbolique c'est un acte politique parce
que face aux déchaînements
d'échaînements de violence des chaînes
de haine dans son victime nos forces de
l'ordre je voudrais vous rappeler qu'en
un peu plus d'un mois ce sont 1000
policiers mille gendarmes 1000
sapeurs-pompiers qui ont été blasés et
parfois grièvement blessé je pense que
face à ce déchaînement nous avons un
devoir nous les élus nous qui sommes des
élus c'est de prendre parti ça n'est pas
de nous taire c'est de dire les choses
de nommer les choses et je pense que
nous devons à la fois prendre partie et
finalement choisir son camp le camp de
l'ordre républicain
ou bien alors le camp d'une certaine
forme d'ambiguïté et même de complicité
parce que quand nous avons vu notamment
Hassan Soline des élus mère ou
parlementaires fin de leur écharpe
tricolore
assister à une manifestation qui était
interdite et dans tout le monde savait
qu'elle allait mal se terminer il faut y
voir je crois un signe de complicité qui
n'est pas admissible lorsqu'on est un
élu de la République
notre écharpe tricolore ne peut pas
servir à couvrir les exactions des
cagoule noir ça n'est pas possible de
même que lorsqu'on est fonctionnaire
qui plus est magistrat on doit se tenir
à l'obligation de réserve j'étais
stupéfait du communiqué de presse du
Syndicat de la magistrature parlant de
répression sociale
parlant aussi d'un état de violence
c'est un débordement qui n'est pas
justifiable et qui alimente la défiance
des Français vis-à-vis de la justice
alors un moment donné il faut dire les
choses prendre parti calmement et
réaffirmer que un certain nombre de
dérives cela suffit
ça suffit notamment cette culture de
l'excuse cette culture y considère à une
forme de fascination pour le chaos voire
même le désordre ou la violence
ceux qui lancent des pierres cloutées
sur les policiers ceux qui brûlent les
voitures de gendarmerie qui attaquent
des sapeurs-pompiers ce ne sont pas les
nouveaux damnés de la terre ce sont au
contraire et tout simplement des
nouveaux incendiaires des nouveaux
adversaires de la République et n'ayez
pas la naïveté de voir un seul instant
que la question des retraites celle des
réserves de substitution les concernent
il s'en fiche ce qu'ils veulent ça n'est
même pas mettre à l'arrêt l'économie
française c'est simplement mettre à bas
l'État et aussi la démocratie et je
pense qu'il faut réagir de même que ça
suffit
cet équivalence qui devient
insupportable entre l'usage légitime de
la force et quand cet usage est malmené
et quand il y a des dérives elles
doivent être sanctionnées elles le sont
toujours
et par ailleurs faut équivalente avec un
usage totalement illégitime illégal
justement de la violence il ne saurait y
avoir mes collègues
une équivalence entre ce qui est
illégitime et ce qui est illégal il ne
saurait y avoir d'équivalence entre ce
qui vise à protéger les citoyens les
biens et les personnes et ce qui est de
l'ordre de l'illégalité aucune
équivalence entre ce qui vise à blesser
parfois même à tuer a casser du flic
et ce qui vise au contraire là encore à
protéger
nous avons nous choisi notre camp ça ne
sera jamais le campus neilisme dans
lequel une certaine ultra gauche voire
même une extrême gauche se complet
chevauchant en réalité les passions les
plus autodestructrices ce sont en
réalité les mêmes les mêmes et je
remercie ceux qui sont à gauche de cette
hémicycle de ne pas y avoir à l'époque
participé mais ce sont les mêmes qui
avaient battu le pavé parisien c'était
en novembre 2019 pour une participation
aux côtés des islamistes ce sont les
mêmes qui aujourd'hui battent la
campagne meloise des Deux-Sèvres aux
côtés des anarchistes et des cadres
noirs
donc mes chers collègues nous avons pris
partis nous devons prendre parti nous
avons choisi notre camp c'est celui de
l'ordre républicain d'un ordre juste
d'un ordre calme mais néanmoins
déterminé Charles bélier avait une jolie
formule que vous connaissez sans doute
puisqu'il disait que c'était l'ordre qui
faisait la liberté c'était le désordre
qui faisait la servissement je crois que
on ne doit pas céder justement à cette
forme là encore de dérive de terrorisme
intellectuel qui considère à penser que
il faudrait aller dans le sens
dérégalité dans le sens de ceux qui
veulent enchaîner à servir la République
à la chanlie nous sommes dans le camp de
l'ordre républicain dans le camp des
forces de l'ordre bien évidemment soyons
à leurs côtés soyons aux côtés de celle
et de ceux qui servent au péril parfois
de leur vie la République notre
démocratie française car vous savez
leur uniforme que certains exectre que
certains veulent salir c'était le même
uniforme que portait Arnaud Beltrame
c'est cette uniforme qu'il porte pour
beaucoup d'entre eux au quotidien
c'est avec cet uniforme qu'ils ont prêté
serment de servir de défendre la loi
cette loi que nous faisons que nous
votons ici au Sénat et bien mes chers
collègues je crois que nous avons madame
la ministre une dette une dette
vis-à-vis de une dette lorsqu'ils sont
agressés une dette d'honneur aussi
lorsque leur honneur est attaqué
injustement défendons-les défendons les
dans les mots sans jamais ne rien céder
au discours plein d'ambiguïté
défendez-les et d'un fondant les dans
les actes en leur donnant les moyens
d'exercer leur mission défendant les
aussi bien évidemment madame la ministre
dans la constance dans la cohérence
on ne peut pas donner raison aux
hadistes de Notre-Dame-des-Landes et le
surlendemain combattre les jadistes à
Sainte-Soline tout se tient ou rien ne
tient la constance la cohérence mes
chers collègues défendons défendants nos
forces de l'ordre exprimons-leur notre
gratitude tous quel que soit nos bancs
parce que ce qu'il représente dépasse
transcende tous nos clivages et l'ordre
encore une fois n'appartient à aucun
parti si ce n'est au parti de la
République et nous devons être à leur
côté nous devons exprimer cette
gratitude cette reconnaissance de la
République de la nation de la nation que
nous servons de la nation que eux-mêmes
ils servent au quotidien et bien souvent
et de plus en plus au péril de leur vie
merci de votre attention
dans la suite de la discussion générale
la parole est à Monsieur Jérôme Durin le
groupe socialiste écoliste et
républicain pour 9 minutes
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs messieurs les
Mesdames et Messieurs les Présidents de
groupe monsieur Retailleau a décidé de
nous réunir cet après-midi pour l'étude
d'une proposition de résolution
politique
il y est question de gratitude et de
reconnaissance aux forces aux forces de
l'ordre je ne sais pas si ce texte
bénéficiera de la même gratitude et de
la même reconnaissance chez les forces
de l'ordre tout cela n'ont pas oublié
les 13000 postes de policiers gendarmes
supprimés durant le dernier quinquennat
où LR a été au pouvoir une saignée des
années Sarkozy dont nous sortons à peine
la gratitude aujourd'hui serait plus
convaincante sincère et cohérente s'il
n'y avait eu l'ingratitude d'alors
alors il est vrai qu'avec cette
résolution opportuniste vous ne prenez
pas beaucoup de risques vous me direz
que c'est peut-être le but recherché je
me souviens en effet que lors de la
précédente proposition de loi de
Monsieur Retailleau s'intéressant au
casseurs l'histoire s'était mal terminée
au Conseil constitutionnel pour ce texte
au moins ce ne sera clairement pas le
cas combien même le Conseil
constitutionnel s'intéresserait-il à
cette résolution je ne vois pas trop ce
qu'il pourrait en dire
j'ouvre les guillemets cette proposition
de résolution tant à inviter le
gouvernement à prendre toutes les
mesures qui permet de ramener l'ordre
dans notre pays où la période récente a
vu s'établir une corrélation entre la
violence politique et la violence
physique avez-vous aussi envisagé sur
Retailleau un moment d'inviter le
gouvernement à gouverner voire de lui
rappeler les vertus du dialogue j'ai
passé 4 heures avec des policiers je dis
après midi aucun ne m'a demandé ce que
j'allais voter sur ce texte ils étaient
par contre heureux de me transmettre les
doléances précises satisfait que j'ai
voté la loopy avec les sénateurs
socialistes curieux d'entendre les
critiques sur tel ou tel point de
doctrine il ne serait pas venu il ne
leur serait pas venu à l'idée de me
demander si je soutenais les forces de
l'ordre et pourtant il savait tous que
j'étais de gauche je vais vous rassurer
ils ne m'ont même pas confondu avec un
sympathisant d'ultra gauche
ils ne m'ont pas demandé si je dénonçais
les casseurs et à aucun moment on ne m'a
accusé de terrorisme intellectuel
notre Assemblée a su montrer qu'elle
savait voter des initiatives de bien
commun mais cette résolution n'apporte
rien au débat oui la majorité des
policiers gendarmes est exemplaire oui
le maintien de l'ordre est une matière
difficile mais non votre résolution ne
prend pas en compte la réalité complexe
des dernières semaines vous tentez de
résumer la situation à un état de guerre
de tous contre tous bien manichés bien
sûr que le gouvernement doit maintenir
l'ordre là où nous voyons d'abord une
immense colère sociale et une profonde
inquiétude écologique portée pour
l'essentiel par des millions de
manifestants pacifistes vous ne
diagnostiquez que les débordements que
nous condamnons également de quelques
dizaines d'abrutis dangereux armés de
mauvaises intentions la réalité c'est
que ce n'est pas la faute des
manifestants si la pression ne redescend
pas ce n'est pas de la faute des
manifestants si des journalistes se font
parfois agresser par les forces de
l'ordre ce ne l'est pas de la faute des
manifestants si l'on n'ose plus aller
manifester en famille les
responsabilités sont d'abord à
rechercher du côté du gouvernement à
force de mépriser les corps
intermédiaires de nier l'utiliser ou de
vouloir caricaturer les oppositions
l'exécutif a pu participer à la montée
de la température sociale se
réchauffement politique comme le
réchauffement climatique il n'est pas
inéluctable pour calmer les esprits il
faut entendre les avis contraires
prendre en considération les
manifestants quand ils sont nombreux
évitez de faire monter la colère quand
on passe au journal télévisé criez tout
le monde adore la police dans la période
c'est aussi stupide que de dire la
police tue nos concitoyennes et nos
concitoyens soutiennent majoritairement
les forces de l'ordre mais vous avez
oublié le contexte si cette résolution
politique avait été proposée à nos
suffrages après Magnanville ou après
l'attentat de Charlie Hebdo elle
n'aurait pas eu la même portée déposez
ce texte dans une période où le travail
des forces de l'ordre des questionnés
s'est déclaré à ceux qui critiquent le
travail de la police circulez il n'y a
rien à voir or la critique de la police
elle est légitime et elle est
souhaitable c'est même l'honneur d'une
démocratie que d'interroger toutes ces
institutions évidemment on peut dénoncer
ceux qui disent que le maintien de
l'ordre en France rappelle celui au
Venezuela ou une vague de manifestation
avait fait 115 morts mais on ne peut pas
balayer le fait que nos voisins
européens s'interrogent sur notre police
qui était autrefois un modèle et devient
aujourd'hui un objet de polémique c'est
polémique elles viennent de partout je
n'ai cependant rien contre la tenue de
ce débat que je ne crains pas en ce sens
je diverge de la position tenue par la
majorité de la droite et du centre à
l'Assemblée nationale la semaine
dernière qui a souhaité la classer la
pétition demandant la dissolution de la
bravème je ne suis pas certain de
partager les termes de cette pétition
éminemment politique mais je n'aurais
jamais jeté ainsi au rebut plusieurs
centaines de milliers de signatures de
citoyens qui s'inquiètent de la manière
dont le maintien de l'ordre est assuré
en France on ne sort jamais gagnant
quand on refuse le débat avant la
journée du 6 avril ce 51% des Français
interrogés disent avoir une bonne
opinion des gardiens de la paix dans un
sondage du golf quand ils étaient 61% à
l'affirmer en novembre 2020 un sondage
pourtant mené juste après l'affaire
dites Michel Zecler du nom de ce
producteur violenté par des policiers
dans son studio de musique dans un
sondage est là du 29 mars 62% des
Français estiment que les violences
policières sont marginales et le fait de
dérapage d'une minorité de policiers à
l'inverse 37% considèrent qu'elles ne
sont pas marginales et sont
représentatif d'un phénomène plus
général au sein de la police je vous
laisse discerter sur le verre à moitié
plein ou à moitié vide pour ma croire je
crois que le vert est à deux doigts de
tomber par terre pardon je vous parlais
tout à l'heure du regard international
alors que les JO approchent cela devrait
tous nous inquiéter Stéphane toussel
président du conseil départemental de
Seine-Saint-Denis n'a pas le profil d'un
casseur et bien pour connaître ce qui
peut se passer au quotidien
Seine-Saint-Denis sur le maintien de
leur par la police par exemple lors des
événements du Stade de France Monsieur
s'inquiète monsieur trucel s'inquiète
pour les JO et demande un débat apaisé
je ne suis pas convaincu que cette
résolution participe de ce débat apaisé
tout mais pour autant pas ajouter dans
votre texte vous évoquez ainsi la montée
de la violence en France dans le
discours politique et dans les
manifestations cette violence a
prospérer depuis plusieurs années du
fait de l'immobilisme de la tolérance et
parfois de la bienveillance de certains
responsables politiques à l'égard de ces
auteurs elle est aujourd'hui légitimée
encouragée par des élus qui tiennent des
discours ambivalents ou encore la
violence physique et désormais précédée
jusque dans nos institutions d'une
violence verbale qui tente de justifier
des compartiments aussi illégaux qui
n'admissibles surtout ces points vous
avez raison s'il s'agit bien de dénoncer
l'ultra-droite et pas seulement l'ultra
gauche s'il s'agit dénoncer les
manifestations racistes à Callac et pas
seulement les manifestations écolo à
Sainte-Soline s'il s'agit de dénoncer
les remarques racistes du RN au Palais
Bourbon et pas seulement les discours
militants des insoumis s'il s'agit de
dénoncer la résurrection du guide à
travers des commandos qui se baptisent
vaffen Assas et pas seulement les
étudiants bloqueurs s'il s'agit de
dénoncer la présence de policiers
adjoint sur les boucles telegrammes
d'extrême droite qui menacent de
commettre des attentats d'extrême droite
et pas seulement de dénoncer la LDH
c'est pourquoi nous avons déposé avec
mes collègues du groupe socialiste une
résolution qui plagie votre texte mais
dénonce l'ultra-droite plutôt que
d'appeler à un bien peu coûteux soutien
aux forces de l'ordre ce texte a été
signé par l'ensemble du groupe du groupe
socialiste je ne sais pas si nous
l'inscrirons dans une niche mais les
actualités récentes le justifierait
peut-être je n'ai aucune difficulté nous
n'avons aucune difficulté à dire nous
soutenons la police puisque vous
dénoncez des calceurs et autres menaces
ultra gauche nous comptons sur vous pour
dénoncer pareillement l'ultra-droite
chers collègues nous ne prendrons pas
part au vote sur ce texte
nous ne prendrons papa au vote sur ce
texte nous croyons à la police parce que
nous croyons à la République l'article
12 de la Déclaration des droits de
l'homme le dit clairement la garantie
des droits de l'homme et du citoyen
nécessitent une force publique cette
force est donc instituée pour l'avantage
de tous et non pour l'utilité
particulière de ceux auquel elle est
confiée nous appartenons à une famille
politique qui a donné à la République de
grand ministre de l'Intérieur pierre
joxantais nous croyons à une police
issue des citoyens et au cœur de la
société nous croyons à la police du
préfet Grimaud celle qui participent à
la Concorde républicaine et nous savons
pouvoir compter sur elle nous ne
résignons pas à une police composée de
fonctionnaires mal recrutés
insuffisamment formé et mal utilisé sur
le terrain vous avez choisi par ce texte
d'exprimer une gratitude
inconditionnelle souvent un peu par
leviène une gratitude d'ailleurs assez
stérile pour les forces de l'ordre
elle-même au groupe socialiste nous
préférons exprimer notre soutien de
principe parce que nous ne sommes pas
contre la police notre exig ence de
principe parce que nous avons une haute
idée du rôle républicain des forces de
l'ordre c'est ce qui nous permet
d'exprimer notre inquiétude quand les
circonstances exigent c'est le cas en ce
moment s'agissant du maintien de l'ordre
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à présent à la présidente
Eliane assassy pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et écologiste
chers présidente
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues je dois
dire que c'est avec un certain
étonnement muet rapidement en affligment
que nous avons découvert l'inscription à
l'ordre du jour du Sénat de cette
proposition de résolution notre pays
connaît une crise une crise sociale et
démocratique d'une ampleur rare et cette
crise vous le savez n'aurait pas eu lieu
si un projet de loi promulguant l'âge de
départ à la retraite n'avait pas été
présenté par le gouvernement sans
concertation contre la vie unanime des
syndicats contre une large majorité qui
n'a jamais fléchi de l'opinion publique
sans entendre les mobilisations
considérables Pacifique durant de
longues semaines le président de la
République tente d'imposer par la
contrainte institutionnelle ce texte qui
pour ceux qui vont le subir représentent
une violence considérable l'obstination
du président de la République et de son
gouvernement a durci le débat a fait
monter des tensions mesdames et
messieurs de la majorité sénatoriale
nous vous appelons au sérieux et au
respect nul à gauche de cette hémicycle
ne souhaite la violence chacun connaît
chacun connaît la difficulté du métier
de policier de ces policiers détenteurs
de mission de service public qui doit
faire face à des situations créées par
des choix politiques dont ils ne sont
nullement responsables vous le savez
c'est au soir du 49.3 que le climat a
changé la tension a atteint un sommet la
colère a explosé c'est un fait vous ne
pouvez le nier des feux ont été allumés
des projectiles lancés des membres des
forces de l'ORSE blessés et nous le
regrettons bien entendu et nous avons
toujours j'ai toujours condamné l'action
des groupes violents qui caricaturent
le mouvement social mais comment
pouvez-vous fermer les yeux face à
l'arrestation massive de centaines de
jeunes Nasser garder à vue dans des
conditions juridiques contestables et
contestées combien de manifestants
blessés parfois gravement est-il décend
de déposer un tel texte alors que
certains dans un autre gars cadre à
Sainte Soline ont été gravement blessés
qu'un homme est toujours aujourd'hui
dans le coma alors que l'apaisement le
retour au dialogue le retrait de ce
texte qui a provoqué le chaos offrant à
certains le terrain de leurs excès
devait être la priorité absolue vous
adoptez avec la mise en débat de cette
proposition de résolution outrancière
une posture dangereuse pour notre
démocratie une posture d'amalgame de
menaces voilées de mise en cause de vos
adversaires politiques sur un terrain je
dois dire inquiétant celui de
l'affrontement il n'y a pas de camp du
Bien et du Mal
celui de l'ordre et du désordre vous ne
représentez pas le camp du Bien et de
l'ordre en ayant contribué largement à
enfoncer notre pays dans la crise par
votre vote sur ce projet de loi votre
texte est présenté à une est un prétexte
pardon à une attaque grave contre les
parties de la gauche qui soutiennent le
mouvement social qui
qui visez-vous question monsieur
Retailleau qui visez-vous quand vous
considérez que la violence et légitimée
encouragée par des élus qui tiennent des
discours ambivalents quand vous invoquez
la bienveillance de certains
responsables politiques à l'égard de ces
auteurs sommes-nous nous-mêmes une
menace à l'ordre public
quand nous alertons avec de nombreux
associations dont la LDH aujourd'hui
menacée par le ministre de l'Intérieur
sur des violences policières évidentes
étayées constatées en France comme à
l'étranger la République mesdames et
messieurs de la droite sénatoriale et de
la majorité sénatoriale ne se résume pas
à l'ordre qui sait le moins qu'on puisse
dire n'a pas été son creuset la
République c'est la démocratie et la
justice sociale
démocratie et justice sociale c'est le
projet que nous portons aujourd'hui face
à vous que nous opposons à votre
proposition de résolution profondément
archaïques et réactionnaire raison pour
laquelle nous ne prendrons pas part au
vote
merci madame la Présidente
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à Monsieur Pascal Martin
pour le groupe de l'Union centriste
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues
1143 c'est le nombre de policiers
gendarmes et sapeurs-pompiers blessés
depuis le début des manifestations
contre la réforme des retraites à ce
chiffre alarmant derrière lequel
derrière lequel pardon ce cache tant de
réalité humaine s'ajoute les 47
gendarmes prises en charge par les
secours lors du dramatique épisode de
sainte Soline le 25 mars dernier
depuis plusieurs années les forces de
sécurité de notre pays sont la cible
d'un nombre inédit d'actions violents
d'actes violents et brutaux dans le
sillage des épisodes
Notre-Dame-des-Landes et gilets jaunes
ces agressions atteint un degré
d'intensité rarement observé et
particulièrement préoccupant
ces violences sont souvent le fait
d'individus instrumentalisants
dangereusement le droit de manifester
pour s'attaquer au symbole et aux
institutions de la République quand il
ne s'agit pas tout simplement de casser
du flic
ces professionnels de l'affrontement
violent nuisent par leurs actes à
l'image de celles et ceux qui exercent
très légitimement un droit fondamental
pour notre démocratie celui de
manifester pire il rendent impossible
l'exercice serein de ce droit en
s'attaquant volontairement à nos forces
de l'ordre et au service de secours
nous n'aurons de cesse de défendre les
femmes et des hommes qui protègent nos
institutions et nos concitoyens je salue
à ce titre l'initiative conjointe des
deux présidents de groupes de la
majorité sénatoriale Bruno retaillod et
Hervé Marseille permettant l'examen
aujourd'hui de la présente proposition
de résolution
c'est un écho puissant à ce que beaucoup
de Français ressentent et constate au
quotidien
en dépit de ce que veulent nous faire
croire les professionnels de l'agitation
et du désordre les Français ne sont pas
dupes à l'occasion d'un récent sondage
85% des Français condamnent les
violences contre les forces de l'ordre
personne ne nous fera croire que nous
vivons dans un état policier personne ne
nous fera croire non plus que nos forces
de l'ordre sont des agents du chaos
personne ne nous fera croire que nos
policiers doivent je cite aller se faire
soigner pour reprendre les mots
révoltants de Monsieur Mélenchon
mes chers collègues il est de notre
responsabilité d'apporter un soutien
clair et sans ambiguïté à ces femmes et
ses hommes qui font la République au
quotidien
notre engagement leur côté est total
mais il n'est pas aveugle
dans le monde dans lequel nous vivons
policiers et gendarmes sont
particulièrement exposés et sont soumis
à une pression constante
face aux provocations aux insultes au
crachat au coût des dérapages ont pu
avoir lieu
inutile de le nier
ces incidents doivent faire l'objet
d'investigation et être le cas échéant
sanctionné 36 enquêtes ont été ouvertes
par l'IGPN et deux par l'iggn depuis les
premières manifestations contre la
réforme des retraites je souhaite
qu'elles permettent de faire toute la
lumière sur des actes qui bien que
regrettable n'en demeure pas moins isolé
de la même manière
il est normal que la justice ait été
saisie après les affrontements de sainte
Soline des personnes ont été blessées et
les légitimes qu'elle veuillent savoir
comment on en est arrivé là
si des incidents existent ils ne
reflètent en rien
l'exemplarité et le sang froid dont font
preuve l'écrasante majorité de nos
forces de l'ordre alors qu'elles ont été
particulièrement sollicitées parfois
plusieurs jours d'affilée au cours des
derniers mois
quelques agitateurs de premier ordre
aimeraient nous faire croire que dans
toute cette histoire les casseurs sont
les victimes et les policiers les
bourreaux que sans gendarmes
ignorait pas eu de dégradation à Sainte
Soline que sans policiers il n'y aurait
pas eu d'incendie à la Rotonde
encore une fois les Français ne sont pas
dupes ils savent que le maintien de
l'ordre est un exercice très compliqué
qui impose parfois l'emploi de la force
publique
les appels à la dispersion ne suffisent
pas toujours face aux jets de pavés au
mortier d'artifice au lancer de cocktail
Molotov et boule de pétanque
bien sûr l'utilisation des armes dont
dispose les forces de l'ordre pour
maintenir l'ordre doit être proportionné
et encadré je pense notamment lanceur de
balles de défense LBD et aux grenades de
désencerclement
comme lors des manifestations des gilets
jaunes nous avons vu ressergir des
polémiques sur l'utilisation des LBD
nous considérons que le problème ce
n'est pas le LBD en lui-même c'est
l'usage qui peut malheureusement être
fait par des agents insuffisamment
formés à leur maniement
il serait irresponsable de priver les
CRS et gendarmes mobiles de ces termes
intermédiaires sans proposer aucune
solution de remplacement
ces outils doivent être confiés à des
professionnels du maintien de l'ordre
capable de les employer avec précision
dans des situations complexes
d'affrontement
c'est même situation d'affrontements
reflète dans tous les cas l'échec d'un
dialogue et l'achauffement d'une
concertation mais qui refuse le dialogue
et la concertation dans notre pays
prenons l'exemple de sainte Soline
tout se passe comme si les manifestants
les plus radicaux incarnaient une forme
de résistance face à un pouvoir
arbitraire justifiant les violences dont
ils se sont rendus coupables tout se
passe comme s'il n'y avait pas eu
d'études d'impact sur les méga bassines
concluant leur utilité dans l'adaptation
au changement climatique et pour la
souveraineté alimentaire de la France
tout se passe comme si l'ensemble des
parties intéressées n'avait pas été
entendu dans le cadre des comités de
bassins et des commissions locales de
l'eau dont la représentativité n'est
mise en doute par personne tout se passe
comme si à tous les niveaux de la
gestion de l'eau les responsables élus
n'avaient pas tranché en faveur de
l'aménagement des bassines conformément
au mandat l’orient été confiée tout se
passe enfin comme si les convictions ou
plutôt l'idéologie de certains devaient
prévaloir par la violence sur des
décisions de justice sans que la police
de la République ne puisse légitimement
intervenir
mes chers collègues les affrontements de
sainte Soline incarnent en effet une
forme de résistance à l'arbitraire la
résistance de décision démocratique
confirmée par la justice défendue par
nos forces de l'ordre face à
l'arbitraire d'une mouvance extrêmement
violente
persuadée qu'elle détient une légitimité
venant dont on ne sait où et qu'elle
voudrait imposer à tous au nom d'un
prétendu intérêt supérieur
1143 blessés c'est le coup humain de
cette aveuglement c'est le triste bilan
de cette rage de cette haine contre
l'État et ses représentants
1143 policiers gendarmes et
sapeurs-pompiers blessés depuis un mois
ayant moi-même été dans une vie
intérieure sapeur-pompiers
professionnels je tiens également à
dresser un hommage particulier à la à
l'ensemble des agents qui participent au
secours et à la sécurité civile dans
notre pays
ils sont là pour protéger la vie nos
concitoyens et pour cela force est de
constater qu'il risque chaque jour la
leur
aucune aucun scrupule de la part des
casseurs professionnels que j'évoquais
précédemment qui n'hésitent plus à s'en
prendre à des sapeurs-pompiers tentant
d'éteindre un incendie ou des
urgentistes soignants en manifestants
blessés
pourtant sans ces apports pompiers et
sans ces urgentistes le bilan humain des
manifestations seraient autrement plus
dramatique par leur dévouement et leur
sens du service il contribuent à apaiser
la situation c'est pourquoi en
responsabilité en tant que défenseur de
l'ordre républicain avec mes collègues
du groupe de l'Union centriste nous
voterons en faveur de cette proposition
de résolution exprimant par la même
notre profonde gratitude notre
reconnaissance et notre soutien aux
policiers et gendarmes je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
merci chers collègues la parole est à
présent à Monsieur Stéphane Ravier au
titre des sénateurs n'appartenant à
aucun groupe
monsieur le Président Madame le ministre
mes chers collègues après avoir œuvré
récemment avec vous pour la création de
200 nouvelles brigades de gendarmerie
dans le pays je tenais à prendre la
parole pour exprimer ma gratitude et ma
reconnaissance aux membres des forces de
l'ordre déployer sur le tout le
territoire national et en particulier
sur le territoire Marseille je tiens à
saluer avec vous la mémoire d'Arnaud
blanc gendarme du GIGN tu es le 25 mars
sans une opération contre leur paillage
illégal en Guyane c'est dans cette même
Amérique centrale et du Sud que
l'extrême gauche dite française ennemi
de l'ordre de l'autorité dans son propre
pays trouve ses meilleures amies les
Chaves malduro Castro apôtres de
l'effondrement économique de la
suppression des libertés fondamentales
et dans la répression policière
sanglante car il faut dire les choses si
nous subissons un tel niveau de violence
envers les forces de l'ordre dans des
plaises aux falsificateurs et aux
menteurs ses principalement l'oeuvre de
la nouvelle union révolutionnaire des
gauches
cette gauche des hémicycles légitimement
l'extrême gauche activiste et Zadiste à
Paris à Sainte-Souline à Bordeaux à
Marseille ils sont présents dans les
rues et dans les facs aux côtés de la
racaille antifa et autres Black Bloc
nous avons vu cette ancienne dealer
devenu député crachez verbalement sur la
police tandis que des agents assurés ça
sécurité et protégé son domicile jour et
nuit nous avons entendu Monsieur
Mélenchon on appelait à la rééducation
des policiers il est temps de rappeler à
fidèle Hugo Mélenchon que la République
c'est eux le leader maximo de l'islamo
gauchisme ferait mieux de se rééduquer
lui-même et de rééduquer ses députés qui
hurlent aux violences policières au
prétendues violences policières mais qui
réintègre un de leurs collègues et qui
frappe son épouse
monsieur katnès on le sait et pour que
toute la France soit insoumise sauf sa
femme pour que la République pour que la
France surtout ne sombre dans le chaos
auquel rêve et œuvrent la nébuleuse
gauchiste 6700 policiers 3300 gendarmes
ont été blessés en service en 2020 le
seul racisme systémique qui existe dans
notre pays et le racisme anti-frique
vociféré par une certaine gauche et
l'extrême gauche une haine des forces de
l'ordre largement partagée dans les
cités de la diversité ou la police y est
perçue non seulement comme les
représentants de l'ordre mais aussi
comme les représentants de la France que
la racaille déteste plus que tout c'est
extrême gauche anarchiste anti-française
embrigade les révoltés des causes
sociales et du racisme anti français
pour en faire des soldats de la haine
anti-flics notre pays qui a vibré à la
mort héroïque d'Arnaud Beltrame et les
crins précieux d'un processus de
civilisation qui nous a transmis l'idéal
chevaleresque ce sont ces figures
d'abnégation qui fédèrent le pays et
continue d'écrire le récit national
comme le 24 mars 2018 je salue ici tous
ceux qui sont prêts à sacrifier leur vie
pour protéger la nôtre cette proposition
de résolution à le mérite d'identifier
de mettre face à face ce qui se trouve
dans le camp de la nation et ceux qui
sont dans le camp de ses ennemis que
chacun choisisse pour ma part ça se
rouge et à leur supplétif je suis et je
serai toujours dans le camp des Bleus
merci mon chers collègues la parole est
maintenant la présidente Nathalie
Delattre
pour le groupe du Rassemblement
démocratique social européen
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues je veux tenir ici
une position sans équivoque le groupe
RDSE condamne sans détour tous les actes
de violence commis notamment par des
casseurs lors des manifestations qui ont
eu lieu ces dernières semaines très
largement nous condamnons toutes les
attaques portées à l'égard des policiers
des gendarmes et parfois même des
pompiers de notre sécurité civile sur
notre territoire tout le monde se
souvient de l'hommage fait aux forces de
l'ordre pendant les manifestations
contre le terrorisme en 2015 nous étions
déjà convaincus avant ces drames du
courage et du dévouement de nos agents
rien n'a changé depuis cependant
j'observe cher certains de nos
concitoyens un sentiment de colère de
plus en plus tranché un rejet de l'État
et de la collectivité j'aimerais
toutefois redire à ceux qui doutent de
l'intérêt de nos institutions qu'ils ne
doivent pas oublier tous les services
qu'elle nous rendent au quotidien
policiers et gendarmes s'inscrivent dans
un ensemble de services publics qui vont
des hôpitaux établissements scolaires en
passant par les réseaux routiers ou les
services d'assurance chômage notamment
ce qui hurle des slogans Antipolis
sont-ils conscients englober le reste
ils sont pour nous de même nature que
les violences à l'égard des enseignants
notre groupe a porté ce sujet de la
violence à l'égard des institutions en
défendant ma loi visant à soutenir les
aides et leurs familles victimes
d'agression
le rejet de toute autorité
institutionnelle ne saurait être admis
en même temps qu'il doit nous interroger
vivre en société c'est aussi se
soumettre à la contrainte sociale pour
reprendre une formule du juriste bordé
de les Léon duguy je cite une société ne
pourrait exister s'il n'y avait pas de
discipline sociale si une règle ne
défendait pas certaines choses et
n'ordonnait pas certaines autres aux
individus qui la composent je considère
que la désobéissance civile n'est pas
une option dans notre République et
choquante quand elle est prenait par des
élus de cette même République qu'il se
devrait de défendre elle est d'autant
moins qu'elle est souvent portée par
idéologie douteuses entre obscurantisme
et complotisme nous n'y adhérons pas
dans son exposé des motifs la
proposition de résolution indique qu'il
est inacceptable et dangereux de
renvoyer deux ados
force de l'ordre et casseurs évidemment
toutefois ne pas accepter la comparaison
n'implique pas de renoncer à toute
observation critique certaines images
restent choquantes et peuvent mettre mal
à l'aise il est ainsi possible d'être
révolté face à l'incendie de la porte de
la mairie de Bordeaux mais de ne pas
être absolument serein en voyant tourner
en boucle des images de tir de LBD et de
Gide grenade oui nous pouvons être
reconnaissants du travail quotidien des
agents de police et de gendarmerie tout
en nous inquiétant de la dérive d'une
poignée d'entre eux lorsque nous
entendons certains enregistrements
cependant s'inquiéter d'une augmentation
même marginale des violences policières
c'est s'inquiéter plus largement de
l'augmentation de la violence dans notre
société il faut donc se préoccuper de la
santé mentale de nos agents de leur état
d'épuisement des situations auxquelles
ils sont confrontés quotidiennement
mais il nous faut aussi veiller à ce que
notre police soit irréprochable et que
chaque dérive soit sanctionné avec la
plus grande fermeté en qualité de
parlementaire nous devons les
accompagner les soutenir par exemple en
leur accordant les moyens nécessaires
afin qu'ils puissent exercer leur métier
dans des conditions décentes en
conclusion mes chers collègues notre
groupe veut réaffirmer avec force sa
gratitude et sa reconnaissance aux
membres des forces de l'ordre aussi nous
voterons pour cette proposition de
résolution je vous remercie
merci cher président à part l'état
présent à Monsieur Olivier Pacaud pour
les républicains
[Applaudissements]
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
sans bouclier tu n'es rien tout
gladiateur touche chevalier le sait bien
j'aimerais rappeler à mon tour combien
la place des forces de l'ordre est
cruciale dans nos sociétés démocratiques
combien nous leur sommes redevable elle
a quelque chose à voir avec ce qui est
au fondement de nos sociétés civilisées
le contrat social qui ne serait en effet
qu'un vœu s'il n'y avait qu'une force à
même de le rendre exécutoire de comptoir
de contraindre aux besoins par la
coercition physique les individus qui
refusent de le respecter
c'est parce que nous savons qu'il existe
une force capable d'imposer le respect
des lois que nous pouvons jouir
paisiblement de nos existences
la police apporte la force au droit elle
arme l'ordre démocratique contre ceux
qui voudraient s'y soustraire ou lui en
substituer un autre injuste et
arbitraire en somme pour paraphraser de
Blaise Pascal elle permet à ce qui est
juste d'être fort sans police ou en
assurer le respect point de contrat
social le droit ne serait que de ventes
d'encre sur d'insignifiante page de code
c'est donc tout notre ordre social
démocratique qui même imparfait repose
sur l'existence de cette force
permettant d'éviter la guerre de tous
contre tous comme la si bien décrit
Thomas Hobbs que cela soit clair
manifester son soutien aux policiers et
sa reconnaissance pour leur engagement
ne revient pas à prendre parti contre la
liberté de manifester la rhétorique
stérile qui voudrait dresser les
manifestants contre les forces de
l'ordre est inapte les unes ne sont pas
là pour entraver la liberté des autres
mais au contraire pour la garantir
notamment contre le noyotage des
manifestations pacifiques par des
perturbateurs qui trouvent une
couverture à leur méfaits
c'est ce dernier risque qui de nos jours
met le plus en péril à la fois la
sécurité des manifestants et l'intégrité
des forces de l'ordre
avant l'irruption des Black Blocs dans
les cortèges syndicaux tous les
observateurs relevaient le faible nombre
d'insistants et saluait le bon
déroulement des rassemblements la
coopération des organisateurs c'est donc
aux agresseurs de policiers aux
incendiaires de poubelles au briseur de
vitrine au lanceur de pavés qu'il faut
jeter la pierre ils sont les seuls
fautifs des infusions de violences que
l'on a conserve observé pardon de sainte
Soline à Paris
la réprobation à leur endroit doit être
unanime car le droit de manifester n'est
pas le droit à la chiant Lee qui
pourrait en discontenir qui s'offusquera
que la force soit rester à la loi
certainement pas nos devanciers voyons
nos vieux textes Jérôme Durin incité la
Déclaration des droits de l'homme et des
citoyens je vous citerai les
constitutions de 80 11 93 et 1848 qui
évoque le droit de manifester qui est
consacré mais qui est systématiquement
assorti d'une exigence la non-violence
la seule liberté alors reconnue et celle
de j'ouvre les guillemets se rassembler
paisiblement sans arme et en
satisfaisant aux lois de police dans le
respect de la liberté d'autrui et de la
sécurité publique cette conciliation
entre liberté et ordre public est un
invariant dans notre tradition juridique
elle structure la façon dont notre droit
conçoit l'étendue et les limites de la
liberté de manifester devrions-nous
considérer avec mensuétude les violences
des Black Blocs et pousser des cris
d'orfray lorsque la police intervient
pour y mettre fin quelle triste
enchantement a conduit certains esprits
à cette inversion des coupables et des
victimes des fauteurs de troubles et des
gardiens de la paix civile qu'est-il
reproché à la police de riposter lorsque
l'on s'en prend à elle de se défendre
lorsqu'un millier de ses agents est
blessé plus ou moins gravement par des
assauts pénalement et moralement
inacceptables lui en veut-on de ne pas
abandonner nos rues à une poignée de
casseurs de s'interposer lorsque des
commerces saccagés d'escorter des
pompiers venant éteindre des incendies
ce que ces contempteurs reprochent à la
police et bel et bien de ne pas désarmer
face à une violence qu'il cautionne
peut-être dans le secret de leur cœur il
blâme la police de faire ce pourquoi
elle a été instituée préserver l'ordre
républicain établi par les lois que
notre société c'est prescrite à travers
ses institutions démocratiques ce
faisant il répudit le contrat social qui
nous lie c'est pourquoi nous devons nous
autres sénateurs témoigner notre
gratitude envers les défenseurs des
droits que sont les policiers leur
redire notre confiance qu'entraîner la
police dans la boue la couvrir
d'accusation infamante est devenue le
fonds de commerce médiatique d'une
partie de la classe politique non
nous n'accepterons pas que le bruit et
la fureur soit des codiciles au contrat
social non les compagnies républicaines
de sécurité n'ont pas vocation à devenir
de la chair à blackblox non nous ne
laisserons pas la police être livré à
quelques indices que ce soit dans
l'opinion publique sans bouclier nous
sommes faibles toutes démocratie le sait
bien
merci cher collègue
et la parole est à Monsieur Franck
Menonville pour les indépendants
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues
nous avons assisté ces dernières
semaines
un véritable déchaînement de violence
dans notre pays d'aimer heries ont été
incendiés de très nombreux
parlementaires ont été la cible
d'attaque y compris dans leur domicile
on ne compte plus les devantures de
magasins et les véhicules incendiés
détruits voilà l'image que nous livrons
au monde chaque jour de manifestation
les forces de l'ordre affrontent des
individus armés décidés à casser à
incendier voire à tuer ce sont des
cocktails monothéops des boules de
pétanque et des battes de baseball qui
ont été employés contre nos policiers
nos gendarmes le 26 mars dernier à
Sainte-Soline tout cela bien évidemment
pour une manifestation non violente
alors pour cette constater que l'ultra
gauche attaque aujourd'hui délibérément
notre République et dans notre et notre
démocratie la France doit cesser d'être
la terre de jeu européenne de ses
factions extrémistes les mouvements
d'une ultra gauche doivent être démontés
il faut lutter contre la complaisance
intellectuelle et politique aux
médiatique envers ses groupuscules la
réponse pénale en cas d'agression contre
les un dépositaire de l'autorité
publique doit être absolument renforcé
dans notre pays afin d'être enfin
dissuasive ce qui avait promis de
transformer l'Assemblée nationale en ZAD
cela même ont empêché le débat
démocratique par une guérilla indigne du
Parlement et sont aujourd'hui dans la
rue à leur côté aux côtés des casseurs
les Français ont des opinions diverses
ils ont un point de il est un point sur
lequel ils sont néanmoins accordés c'est
que la démocratie
et doit nous gouverner
ce qui préserve de l'arbitraire c'est
l'observance des formes disaient
Benjamin Constant représentant de la
nation il est de notre devoir de
réaffirmer que la violence n'est pas un
moyen d'expression légitime d'un autre
démocratie et dans notre République nous
avons et nous aurons des désaccords
c'est normal les gouvernements feront
toujours face à une opposition c'est
naturel et c'est là le principe de la
démocratie et il importe cependant
qu'elle s'exprime par la voie
démocratique
alors que dans notre pays connaît donc
des accès de violence je veux rendre
hommage au nom du groupe les
indépendants aux hommes et aux femmes
qui dédient leur vie à la protection de
nos concitoyens et de nos institutions
ce sont eux qui protègent la France
contre la délinquance et le terrorisme
eux qui sécurisent également les grands
événements que notre pays s'apprête à
accueillir et c'est encore qui doit
faire face aujourd'hui à une violence
encouragée par quelques irresponsables
politiques prises pour cible par des
révolutionnaires de salon les forces de
l'ordre le sont ensuite dans la rue
depuis le début des manifestations on
compte plusieurs centaines de blessés
154 pour la seule journée de jeudi
dernier
la veille d'une malgré l'intensité donc
des tensions malgré le risque qu'ils
encourent nos policiers nos gendarmes
constituent continuent d'exercer leur
métier avec un grand professionnels avec
courage et sans froid ils font face à
des individus qui cherchent en
permanence à provoquer l'embrasement à
la veille d'une nouvelle journée de
mobilisation je veux au nom de mon
groupe leur dire qu'ils peuvent compter
sur notre soutien nous exprimons
aujourd'hui encore notre reconnaissance
au gardien de l'ordre républicain
contrairement aux manifestants la police
et la gendarmerie ne sont les défenseurs
d'aucune idéologie ils sont au service
de tous les Français et de nos
institutions républicaines beaucoup de
nos collègues s'est élevés suite à la
question au gouvernement du président
maluré pour rendre hommage à nos forces
de l'ordre la région la résolution que
nous examinons aujourd'hui fait donc
partie des textes qui doivent nous
réunir et réunir les républicains le
groupe Les Indépendants donc soutiendra
bien évidemment l'adoption à l'unanimité
de cette résolution et je voudrais
vraiment saluer et permet des mois de
conclure en salutant l'initiative
conjointe des présidents retaillaux et
Marseille je vous remercie
merci chers collègues le président
guitare a renoncé à son temps de parole
et maintenant donc la parole revient à
Monsieur Xavier yakovelli pour le groupe
RDP
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
chers collègue la proposition de
résolution que nous examinons
aujourd'hui et certainement révélatrice
d'un climat social et politique que
notre pays connaît depuis une vingtaine
d'années en effet s'il y a bien un
constat que nous partageons c'est le con
la contestation auquel notre pays est
confronté sont de plus en plus violentes
ces phénomènes de violence ne touchent
pas que la France rappelez-vous ces
scènes de guérilla et d'émeutes lors du
G20 de Hambourg en 2017 avec trois jours
de déferlantes de violences et de haine
où le G20 G8 pardon de Rostock en 2007
où l'on comptait plus d'un millier de
blessés ou encore le G20 de Londres
l'apparition des zones à défendre les
fameuses ZAD en réalité des véritables
zones de non-droits est également devenu
un phénomène récurrent chez nos voisins
là aussi en janvier 2023 à luzerat en
Allemagne de violences affrontements ont
eu lieu au cours duquel des pollutions
essayaient des tirs d'engins
pyrotechnique et déjà de projectile
faisant plus de 70 blessés toujours en
janvier 2023 à Atlanta pour s'opposer à
la construction d'une pas mal de police
des manifestants ont entraîné la mort
ont entraîné un mort et de nombreux
blessés
et cette mouvance internationaliste
touche également la France cette
nouvelle génération d'activistes d'ultra
gauche ou d'ultra-droite ce structure au
printemps 2006 lors de la mobilisation
contre les CPE il méprise les
mobilisations institutionnelles il
méprise les manifestations encadrés ils
encouragent l'insurrection et profitent
de ses contestations pour semer le chaos
plusieurs lieux de fortes contestation
sont devenus tristement célèbres à
sievens avec le décès d'un jeune homme
et de et 56 policiers et gendarmes
blessés à Notre-Dame-des-Landes ou sans
huit gendarmes ont été blessés et la
saisine de 800 engins incendiaires plus
de 50 kg d'artifice et engins explosifs
artisanaux et 10 armes blanches
récupérées cela en dit long sur la
détermination de ces groupes d'ultra
gauche à mettre en péril la vie de ceux
qui nous protègent
au printemps 2016 lors de la
contestation contre la loi dit de
travail la mouvance a atteint un niveau
de violence jusqu'à leur inégalée depuis
et nous voyons bien du mouvement des
gilets jaunes jusqu'à la mobilisation
contre la réforme des retraites l'ultra
gauche et l'ultra-droite un filtre
toutes les revendications pour les
radicaliser c'est contestations nous le
voyons bien entretiennent des liens
entre elles elle mais également avec des
mouvances étrangères c'est comme cela
qu'à Sainte-Soline des forces de l'ordre
ont été également confrontés à des
éléments radicaux venant d'Italie
d'Allemagne ou encore de Belgique
d'ailleurs selon la préfète des
Deux-Sèvres tout porte à croire que les
activistes violents visaient davantage
les forces de l'ordre pour elle-même et
à travers elle les institutions
républicaines
personne est surtout les organisateurs
ne pouvaient alors ignorer la violence
qui se déchaînerait lors des
rassemblements qu'ils avaient préparés
le directeur général de la police
nationale de la gendarmerie nationale
pardon indiquait que les éléments
radicaux avaient pour objectif de mettre
en échec avec la capacité des gendarmes
à maintenir l'ordre public et assurer la
protection des institutions et cette
gravité et c'est avec gravité chers
collègues que on ne peut que regretter
la duplicité de certains membres de
notre Parlement ces élus portent une
lourde responsabilité dans leur attitude
dans leurs propos et dans leur silence
en participant à ces manifestations
interdites on ne condamnant pas
clairement les violences à l'encontre de
nos forces de l'ordre ces élus jouent un
jeu dangereux
et comme un slogan simple qui utilise
souvent ce qui n'obtiendrait pas par les
urnes il obtiendrait par la rue
derrière cette idéologie il y a une
réalité qui cautionne la violence
physique la violence verbale et la
violence morale si le groupe RDPI
s'allume et votre a pour cette
proposition de résolution exprimant
reconnaissance et gratitude du Sénat aux
forces de l'ordre je tiens à rappeler
que le renforcement des moyens
l'amélioration des conditions de travail
et la revalorisation des carrières sont
les meilleures la meilleure preuve de
gratitude et de reconnaissance que
l'État peut faire face aux envers les
forces de sécurité intérieure le premier
quinquennat du président Macron a été
marqué par un renforcement considérable
des moyens à louer au ministère de
l'intérieur avec je rappelle 10
milliards d'euros de budget
supplémentaires 10000 policiers
gendarmes recrutés le renouvellement de
la moitié du parc automobile le paiement
de plusieurs millions d'heures
supplémentaires additionnés et non payés
pendant plusieurs années 2023 est la
première année de mise en œuvre des
mesures prévues par la loi du 24 janvier
2023 d'orientation et de programmation
du ministère de la fameuse locmin ce
texte prévoit un renforcement et un
effort budgétaire inédit de 15 milliards
d'euros entre 2023 et 2027 qui permettra
notamment le doublement de la présence
des forces de l'ordre sur le terrain
d'ici 2030 à cette fin le ministère de
l'Intérieur bénéficiera de 8500
créations d'emplois d'ici 2027 en plus
des 10000 que nous avons fait lors du
précédent quinquennat rien que cette
année les effectifs des forces de
l'ordre seront augmentées de 2857
emplois temps plein ces nouveaux
gendarmes et policiers armeront
prioritairement les nouvelles de Sam
brigades notamment en milieu rural qui
doivent être créés d'ici 2027 je pense
également à la poursuite de la
revalorisation des carrières et des
compétences et des métiers dans la
police nationale plusieurs mesures sont
par ailleurs prévues pour renforcer
l'accompagnement social des personnes
elle et de leur famille je pense
notamment à l'amélioration des aides aux
blessés et de l'aide à la reconstruction
par le sport la densification du réseau
de psychologues cliniciens ou encore la
mise en place de nouvelles ADS pour les
gardes d'enfants en horaires atypique et
décalé
c'est par toutes ces mesures chers
collègues et par le vote de la locmi que
nous avons eu dans cette hémicycle que
nous apportons un soutien concret plein
et entier aux forces de l'ordre c'est
pourquoi au nom du groupe RDPI nous
apporterons clairement notre pleine
reconnaissance et la gratitude aux
forces de l'ordre en votant cette
résolution je vous remercie merci chers
collègues la parole est à présent à
Monsieur François bonhomme pour le
groupe les républicains
[Applaudissements]
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
jusqu'à mi-mars à l'appel de inter
syndicale les manifestations contre la
réforme des retraites se déroulaient à
peu près un peu partout sur le
territoire de manière organisée
Pacifique
manifestants gouvernement ou médias se
féliciter du bon déroulement de cet
exercice de droit démocratique mais le
16 mars dernier la décision de la
première ministre de recourir au 49-3 a
été le point de départ de violence
urbaine qui ont ensuite émaillé toutes
les manifestations notamment celle du 23
mars ou encore celle du 5 avril dernier
nous avons assisté le 25 mars dernier
dans une autre contexte un déchaînement
de violence alors même que la
manifestation était interdite sur le
site des retenues d'eau à Sainte Soline
le bilan de ces mois d'affrontement est
lourd près de 2000 interpellations
plusieurs centaines d'atteintes à des
institutions de la République et plus de
300 000 de 1300 policiers gendarmes ou
pompiers blessés 2500 incendies sur la
voie publique dont certains menaces
certains immeubles et leurs habitants
ainsi un drame a été invité de peu à
Paris ou des personnes dont des enfants
ont dû être évacués par nos forces de
sécurité devant ce chaos celles-ci on
fait preuve de beaucoup de sang-froid
pour assumer malgré tout leur mission de
protection des biens et des personnes
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
souhaitons rendre ici hommage et leur
apporter toute notre soutien aujourd'hui
c'est pourtant trouvé une partie des
élus au sein de diverses associations
prétendument humanitaires pour se livrer
à une mise en cause indécente contre les
policiers et gendarmes en les accusant
de brutalité et de violences à l'égard
des manifestants nous avons assisté ici
un renversement des valeurs ou les
agresseurs deviennent des agressés
nos forces de l'ordre en tua contenir
les assauts répétés de certains indignés
professionnels qui ont été qualifiés de
simples promeneurs depuis quand les
personnes qui souhaitent manifester ou
protester doivent s'équiper de cocktail
Molotov de boules de pétanque de
marteaux de bas de baseball des manches
de pioche ou de pavés à Sainte Soline
c'est Arsenal qualifié de festifs
étaient complété par des bonbons de gaz
des aérosols des bidons d'essence ou
encore des mortiers d'artifice une
partie était manifestement venue avec
l'intention de taper du flic encouragé
par les slogans stupides la police tue
les fourgons en feu de la gendarmerie ne
laissaient pas de place au doute sur
leur détermination en découdre
il y a là je crois mes chers collègues
une complaisance et même une fascination
pour la violence que je ne m'explique
pas venant de certains mouvements
d'extrême gauche comme les Black Blocs
qui rêvent d'insurrection de grands
soirs
leur objectif attaquer et détruire la
société capitaliste et ses institutions
républicaines naturellement bourgeoises
nos services de renseignement ont
confirmé une stratégie d'infiltration
des mouvements sociaux que dès la
mi-mars l'ultra gauche a organisé afin
de faire basculer les manifestations
pacifiques en des soirées d'émettre
contre tous symboles de l'État et en
premier lieu contre les représentants de
l'ordre républicain les policiers et les
gendarmes
cette violence n'a rien de symbolique
les vitrines des banques assurances et
autres McDo ou encore des grandes
enseignes de commerce en ont fait les
frais également pour cette mouvance le
recours à la violence doit permettre de
susciter un processus dit
insurrectionnel prémices indispensable à
la révolution ou à défaut susceptibles
de mettre fin à nos institutions
actuelles au profit d'une vaporeuse 6e
République
face à cela nous avons constaté
l'impossibilité pour certaines mouvances
qui se disent pourtant démocrate de
condamner clairement les violences
exercées contre nos forces de l'ordre
nous l'avons vu à Sainte Soline on
invoque le droit de manifester mais de
l'autre côté le droit de propriété qui
est un droit naturel imprescriptible sur
l'article de la déclaration de l'homme
ne fait pas problème n'est pas une
question et pourtant les forces de
police ont bien dû être mobilisées pour
protéger l'outil de production de nos
agriculteurs et c'est ça qui doit être
avoir l'esprit quand on veut remettre à
l'endroit les valeurs qui doivent nous
réunir dans ce contexte de violence
contre nos institutions que peuvent
faire les parlementaires pour soutenir
nos forces de l'ordre récemment le
secrétaire général du syndicat Alliance
a demandé une nouvelle loi anti-casseurs
afin d'avoir je le cite les moyens
juridiques et techniques de prévenir les
violences lors de manifestations et de
sanctionner leurs auteurs
le président Retailleau d'ailleurs avait
déposé rappelons-le une proposition de
loi qui à la fin de son processus
législatif avait donné naissance à la
loi d'avril 2019 visant à renforcer et à
garantir le maintien de l'ordre lors des
manifestations de ce genre
malheureusement vous le savez une
décision du Conseil constitutionnel est
venu remettre en cause l'application de
ce texte il semble cependant qu'il
existe une voix pour une réécriture et
le ministre d'armanin a aussi annoncé
devant notre commission des lois que le
décret relatif à la situation des drones
par nos forces de sécurité étaient en
cours d'examen Conseil d'État
dès cet été sur un fin possible d'avoir
recours à ses appareils des fins de
renseignement pour notre part nous
sommes donc prêts à soutenir et apporter
notre contribution pour que nos forces
de l'ordre puisse effectuer leur tâche
difficile de maintien de l'ordre avec
tous les outils juridiques adaptés ce
sera pour nous je crois le meilleur
moyen d'exprimer notre gratitude et
notre reconnaissance aux forces de
l'ordre
voilà et
nous concluons les orateurs avec
Monsieur Pascal Alizard pour les
républicains
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues depuis plusieurs
années l'activité des forces de l'ordre
c'est considérablement accrues sur le
territoire métropolitain du terrorisme
aux manifestations des aides au quartier
ghetto de la lutte contre l'immigration
illégale à la police du quotidien tout
en fait peut-être sujet à la violence
même lors d'événements sportifs festifs
ou culturels cette agitation permanente
mais les forces de l'ordre en tension
érinent les personnels compliquent leur
vie familiale on ne compte plus leurs
heures supplémentaires ni les blessures
parfois graves pour assurer la sécurité
des Français et faire appliquer les lois
je pense également à nos forces en
outre-mer elle doit faire face à une
délinquance différente jeune violente
dans certains territoires et à la
multiplication des trafics en
particulier de stupéfiants
cette violence peut être aussi amplifiée
par des flux migratoires incontrôlés qui
créent des situations explosives comme
c'est le cas à Mayotte en Guyane
l'immigration illégale venue du Brésil
ou du Suriname accentue la prédation sur
les ressources pêche illégales coupe de
bois or paillage pollution des sols et
cours d'eau nos forces travaillent dans
des conditions difficiles et dangereuses
un gendarme d'élite y a perdu la vie il
y a quelques jours le trafic de drogue
particulièrement de cocaïne vers la
métropole mobilise aussi policiers
gendarmes douanier aujourd'hui nous leur
exprimons notre gratitude notre
reconnaissance c'est d'autant plus
nécessaire qu'elles font face à des
individus de plus en plus radicalisés et
désinhibés dont le l'ambition pardon est
clairement de tuer ou de brûler du flic
si vous me permettez cette expression
oui le médecin de l'ordre est une
activité délicate qui exige
professionnalisme et du sang-froid tant
pour assurer la sécurité des personnels
que des citoyens mais cette violence est
globale et ne vise pas que la police ou
la gendarmerie sont aussi ciblées de
nombreux agents du service public des
médecins des pompiers des enseignants
des élus nationaux ou locaux le maintien
de l'ordre en France et certainement
encore perfectible mais madame la
ministre d'autres problèmes sont aussi à
traiter une réponse pénale souvent
faible et surtout je crois des délais de
jugement trop long des individus
délinquants se maintenant sur le
territoire alors qu'il n'avait aucun
titre pour y rentrer voir qu'ils font
l'objet d'une qtf non exécuté
l'internationalisation des casseurs de
l'ultra gauche mais aussi de
l'ultra-droite
je pense tout autant au désespoir
au désespoir au désespoir d'une partie
de la jeunesse entre perte de repères et
éco-ancié et celui des territoires
périphériques en voie de paupérisation
dont en fait les gilets jaunes étaient
l'expression je voudrais leur dire que
la violence n'est jamais la solution et
quelle image nous donnons-nous au monde
en tout cas pas celle du pays de la
liberté alors madame la ministre il
faudra s'attaquer rapidement à ces
problèmes pour éviter que la violence de
ce déchaîne systématiquement sur les
forces de l'ordre et n'aboutissent à des
tragédies que je le crois personne ici
ne souhaite je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
merci chers collègues et à présent la
parole est à Madame Sonia baquet
secrétaire d'État chargé de la
citoyenneté
au nom du gouvernement
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs permettez-moi de
commencer cette allocution en ayant une
pensée émue pour le gendarme Yannick
pierre et l'adjudant de réserve Patrick
Hervé des CD hier au cours d'une
opération de lutte contre la délinquance
routière et plus largement pour la
grande famille de la gendarmerie
nationale qui est une nouvelle fois
endeuillée et paix le lourd tribu de son
engagement
je voudrais ensuite excuser Gérald
Darmanin qui tenait à être ici pour
soutenir cette proposition de résolution
et pour exprimer sa gratitude et sa
reconnaissance aux forces de l'ordre
mais qui est vous le savez au Pays-Bas
avec le président de la République je
tiens également à remercier les
présidents Bruno Retailleau et Hervé
Marseille pour cette proposition de
résolution qui nous donne l'occasion
d'exprimer la gratitude de la nation à
l'endroit de ces femmes et de ses hommes
qui ont choisi parfois au péril de leur
vie comme nous le rappelle tristement
l'actualité de protéger la nôtre avant
de commencer je souhaiterais vous faire
part d'un sentiment personnel En tant
que calédonienne j'ai vécu il n'y a pas
si longtemps que ça les affres d'une
guerre civile fratricide ce que nous
appelons et vous votre assemblée le sait
bien très pudiquement les événements
chez nous je mesure donc toute
l'importance de conserver à tout prix la
paix et je sais que je ne sais que trop
bien le rôle central que joue nos forces
de l'ordre dans cette entreprise
je sais qu'elle fut leur importance
lorsque 2000 d'entre elles sont venues
il y a deux ans assurer l'exercice
serein du droit à l'autodétermination
décalédoniens nous savons ce que nous
leur devons partout elle s'engage pour
la France et les Français à Paris pour
garantir la liberté de manifester à
Sainte Soline pour lutter contre ceux
qui tentent de mettre à genoux notre
République ou à Nouméa à 22000 km de
chez elle pour honorer la parole de la
France dans les outre-mer que ces femmes
et ses hommes qui constituent les forces
de sécurité intérieure soient assurées
de l'entier soutien et de la totale
reconnaissance du ministère de
l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer ces forces
sont les seules garantes de l'ordre
public de l'ordre républicain du seul
ordre qui vaille ce rôle est inscrit
dans la déclaration des droits de
l'homme et du citoyen de 1789 qui
précise dans son article 12 la garantie
des droits de l'homme et du citoyen
nécessitent une force publique cette
force est donc instituée pour l'avantage
de tous
et cette force ce sont les femmes et les
hommes qui s'engagent au quotidien pour
la sécurité des Français ces femmes et
ces hommes sont la force qui garantit le
droit à la liberté contre seul contre
ceux qui veulent saper le fonctionnement
nos institutions et de notre démocratie
la force qui garantit le droit à la
propriété contre ceux qui brûlent les
voitures les immeubles et les portes de
mérite la force qui garantit le droit à
la sûreté et à l'ordre républicain
contre ceux qui pratiquent la guérilla
urbaine et s’en prennent aux outils de
travail de nos agriculteurs ou au
commerce des données de travailleurs cet
engagement au service de la protection
des droits des Françaises et des
Français nos forces de l'ordre le
réalisent partout en France sur le
territoire métropolitain évidemment où
elles ont été particulièrement
sollicitées ces derniers mois mais aussi
dans nos territoires ultramarins
aux Antilles pour lutter contre
l'insécurité et le trafic de drogue qui
gang qui gangrène le territoire en
Guyane pour combattre les cartels et les
orpailleurs je veux d'ailleurs ici avoir
une nouvelle pensée émue pour le major
Arnaud blanc décédé dans l'exercice de
ses fonctions dans cette lutte de chaque
instant contre ceux qui pillent et
détruisent sans vergogne le territoire
guyanais nos forces de l'ordre
interviennent à Mayotte également pour
freiner l'immigration comorienne qui
place nos concitoyens mahorés dans une
situation insoutenable dans le Pacifique
enfin en Polynésie à Wallis-et-Futuna ou
en Nouvelle-Calédonie où elles sont
engagées sur un large spectre de mission
et concours entre autres à la
préservation du fragile écosystème qui
fait la richesse de nos îles océaniennes
pourtant ces dernières semaines cela
même qui garantissent l'État de droit et
la sécurité de tous les Français ont été
la cible d'attaque inacceptable cocktail
Molotov pavé insultes appel à la haine
depuis le 19 janvier première journée de
mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites nous assistons à une montée en
puissance de la violence à l'encontre de
nos forces de l'ordre plus de 1800
policiers et gendarmes ont été blessés
depuis cette date dont
1380 seulement ces quatre dernières
semaines et ces attaques sont d'autant
plus graves lorsqu'elles sont passées
sous silence par certains partis
politiques voire pire lorsque derrière
des critiques politiques injustes se
cachent une bienveillance insidieuse en
faveur des casseurs de Notre-Dame des
Landes et de sainte Soline
nous nous y trompons pas cette violence
cherche à fracturer la société en
s'attaquant aux institutions de la
République en discréditant les forces de
l'ordre et en rejetant la légitimité
parlementaire dans notre pays notre
discours ne doit être ni ambigu ni à
géométrie variable le devoir de nos
forces de l'ordre est avant tout de
permettre l'exercice de la liberté de
manifester lors des manifestations
déclarées et autorisées il en va de
l'honneur des policiers et des gendarmes
de garantir pour chacun d'entre nous
d'exprimer dans le respect de la loi ces
attentes ces opinions sont
mécontentements et son opposition une
fois que cela est dit nous avons toutes
et tous constaté l'extrême violence des
groupuscules dont les membres sont
responsables de grandes violences je
pense notamment à un certain groupement
les soulèvements de la terre dont les
membres ont envahi des entreprises
commis des exactions graves contre les
forces de l'ordre détruit plusieurs
biens et lancer plusieurs appels à
l'insurrection
face à ces organisations factueuses la
main du gouvernement ne tremble pas nous
avons pris les mesures qui s'imposent
pour maintenir l'ordre dans notre pays
c'est pourquoi Gérald Darmanin a engagé
la dissolution de ce groupement je peux
vous assurer de la pleine mobilisation
des services de renseignement pour
anticiper et détecter la formation et
les actions de groupuscules d'ultra
gauche comme d'ultra-droite à l'origine
de nombreux troubles
là aussi sans ambiguïté je le répète
ultra gauche comme ultra droite le
ministère de l'Intérieur et l'outre-mer
saura faire preuve de fermeté à leur
égard
nous avons appris toutes les mesures qui
s'imposent pour appréhender ces fauteurs
de troubles un travail important a été
mené pour rénover la doctrine du
maintien de l'ordre le nouveau schéma
national tient compte des évolutions de
la sociologie revendicatives et intègre
davantage la relation avec les
manifestants il montre d'ores et déjà
des effets encourageants le déroulement
des dernières manifestations témoignent
de la juste adaptation de ces nouveaux
dispositifs notamment en milieu urbain
certes il y a eu des dégradations mais
nous ne déplorons aucun incident majeur
le gouvernement a également pris les
mesures qui s'imposent pour assurer
l'ordre dans notre pays grâce à la loop
me que vous avez largement voté dans
cette hémicycle en effet près de 7500
policiers gendarmes supplémentaires vont
compléter les rangs des forces de
l'ordre et 200 brigades de gendarmerie
sont en cours de création les réserves
opérationnelles de la gendarmerie et de
la police vont être par ailleurs portés
respectivement à 50 000 et à 30000
effectifs pardon
les agents vont aussi bénéficier de
matériel et tenus modernisés le parc
automobile des forces de l'ordre va être
renouvelée à un rythme manuel de 10% en
outre en vue des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques que la France accueillera
en 2024 11 nouvelles unités de force
mobile seront déployées dès cette année
et l'année prochaine sur l'ensemble du
territoire et cette unité de forme force
mobile pardon seront rendues disponibles
par la reprise des sites par les
préfectures de police soyez assurés de
la mobilisation pleinée entière du
ministère dans la préparation de cet
événement essentiel pour notre pays il
en va de l'honneur de la France de
garantir aux forces de l'ordre les
moyens nécessaires pour qu'elles
puissent assurer leur mission avec
dignité et sérénité au service de la
République et de la démocratie la
confiance des Françaises et des Français
en faire envers les forces de l'ordre et
le soutien que nous leur apportons
n'empêche en rien l'exigence de
déontologie et de respect du droit que
nous leur demandons et auxquels il
s'astreigne le corollaire de cette
mission au service de la République
c'est l'exemplarité car à chaque fois
qu'un policier dérape et cela peut
arriver c'est la relation des citoyens
aux forces de l'ordre au ministère de
l'Intérieur et même à la République qui
se dégrade s'il s'avère que des
policiers et des gendarmes sortent
sortent du cadre fixé par la loi si cet
équilibre entre nécessité et
proportionnalité n'est pas respectée
alors il y a des enquêtes et les
responsables sont évidemment sanctionnés
le ministère de l'Intérieur l'IGPN tout
comme la gendarmerie nationale et la
police nationale s'attachent à ce que la
formation des forces de l'ordre aussi
bien initial que continue soit la plus
précise et la plus exigeante possible
mais ne tombons pas dans le piège tendu
par certains aujourd'hui ne transformons
pas ses cas isolés d'utilisation
disproportionnée de la force en
généralité non je le dis clairement il
n'existe pas de violences policières
dans notre pays la violence est à la
main de l'état qui détient le monopole
de la violence légitime tenir un autre
discours se serait jeter l'eau propre
sur ses ouvriers de la sécurité que sont
nos policiers et nos gendarmes
avec Gérald Darmanin nous mesurons ce
que les gendarmes et policiers
accomplissent au quotidien ce que cela
représente pour eux d'engagement
d'abnégation de courage et de sacrifices
et je veux d'ailleurs avoir ici une
pensée particulière pour leur famille et
leurs proches qui eux aussi ont assumer
le poids de cet engagement ces femmes et
ces hommes méritent toute notre estime
notre reconnaissance et les Françaises
et les Français savent bien ce qu'il
leur doivent le rôle essentiel qu'il
joue pour leur permettre de mener une
vie paisible nous en sommes convaincus
ainsi le vote de la présente proposition
de résolution confirmera j'en suis
persuadé le soutien et la reconnaissance
du Sénat et derrière lui les élus locaux
partout en France et celui des
Françaises et des Français aux forces de
l'ordre qui agissent partout dans notre
pays pour notre sécurité je vous
remercie
merci Madame
il va falloir procéder au vote sur la
proposition de résolution et je rappelle
que la Conférence des Présidents a
décidé que les interventions des
orateurs dans le débat valait
explication de vote je peux donc mettre
au voile la proposition de loi en ayant
été saisi d'une demande de scrutin
public par le groupe les républicains
sur l'ensemble du texte il va donc être
procédé au scrutin public dans les
conditions de l'article 56 le scrutin
est ouvert
scrutin est clos
et voici le résultat
votant 250 exprimé 250 pour la
résolution 250 contre 0 et donc adoptée
[Applaudissements]
et je vais de nouveau suspendre quelques
instants pour permettre à chacun de
prendre sa place pour le prochain poil
lors du jour qui est les conclusions de
la CMP JO